انا مش هارب والله ولا حاجه انا بحب مصر
وانا اتولدت فيها وهموت فيها
[موسيقى]
احمد
فؤاد
[موسيقى]
ابويا الحاج فؤاد عامل ايه يا حاج واحشني
والله انا اسف يا حاج انا خدت القرار ده
من غير ما اعرفك ما بخبي عليك حاجه بس
والله يا حاج لو انا قلت لك ما كنتش
هتوافق وكنت هتقول لي عاوزك تحقق حلمك انا
اسف يا بابا بس انا بقيت راجل وعندي احساس
انت تعبت معايا كتير قوي وكنت بتبخل على
نفسك وعلى اخواتي عشان اعرف اصرف على نفسي
وعلى كليتي وعلى سفري وعلى فيتاميناتي
[موسيقى]
احب اشكر حضرتك يا ريس على الدعوه دي
الاكاديميه بجد
انا اول ما عرفت ان حضرتك بعت لي الدعوه
دي كنت مبسوط جدا والله ومصر مليانه مواهب
كتير زي احمد بخدوده بس عاوزين الدعم
[موسيقى]
انا مش هارب والله ولا حاجه